des petites capsules coloré qui renferme
des cafés grands crus pure origine à 27
dans l'illinois brice pomérols a lancé
sa propre marque l'originel son parcours
un master dans une école de commerce et
un premier emploi dans une entreprise de
distribution automatique chercher à
mettre ses plus tourner dans un premier
temps autour autour du service pour
parce que j'aime bien avoir du contact
avec les gens pas forcément à rester
derrière un bureau en bureau toute la
journée et essayez de vous la découvrir
découvrir d'autres personnes et puis
d'avoir ce genre de rapport avec le
professionnel avec des gens c'est là
qu'il s'intéresse aux métiers de
torréfacteurs avec des parents
entrepreneur il décide il ya un an de se
lancer son concept proposé des cafés
unique issu de petites exploitations
agricoles situées dans plusieurs pays du
monde
il est transformé juste une fois ce
niveau de la torréfaction qui encore une
fois artisanale c'est pas du tout une
torréfaction industrielle est
directement mis en capsules
c'est à dire que c'est un produit qui
est 100% naturel il n'ya pas d'additif
des exhausteurs de goût ou autres
produits chimiques pour faire ressortir
un goût non mais vraiment que le café en
valeur une démarche qualitative mise en
avant par le jeune homme ses capsules
vendues entre 32 et 36 centimes d'euros
sont proposés pour le moment sous neuf
références un catalogue que brice espère
bien étoffé prochainement avec des cafés
bio une activité prenante qui lui laisse
tout de même un peu de place pour une
autre passion le rugby
ils pratiquent ce sport à versailles
notamment depuis son adolescence
pour le côté amical il ya aussi le sport
en lui-même que j'apprécie qui a des
valeurs dont on connaît
deux combats de créativité aussi
d'organisation stratégie de soins c'est
aussi un sport stratégies donc ça plein
de plans de belles vertus
une manière de se ressourcer pour
proposer toujours de nouveaux produits
comme ce corner café dessinée aux
entreprises un profil de businessman qui
n'a jamais échappé à son entourage
il ya toujours eu ce côté un peu fibre
entrepreneuriat il a toujours aimé
bosser bosser pour lui avancer faire les
choses et c'est vrai que je le vois et
c'est dans sa personnalité sa ferme
éthier qui lui correspond complètement
et je suis sûr qu'il va qui va très bien
s'en sortir
est-ce qu'il a des défauts et il en a
certainement pas facile on va dire qu'il
a des qualités
un jeune homme parfait donc qui
emménagera le mois prochain dans de
nouveaux locaux à voisins le bretonneux
son souhait pour 2018 que toute l'île de
france découvre les arômes de ses grands
crus